game review my name is Caleb Dundee and
welcome back to game review it probably
has not been too long since you last
have seen a game review on the youtube
channel but for me it's been months
since I recorded one of these so in
those months I did not come up with any
new clapping ideas so please give me all
of your suggestions down in those
comments below and I will hopefully be
struck with inspiration in the meantime
I do have a game for us to review today
this is a game from the clutch chess
tournament going on that was between
Fabiana Cara Juana and Lenny a domingus
of course after the first day of clutch
chess
Fabiana carolina had a crushing lead
over Lenny a Dominguez and I want to
take a look at one of those games that
went really well for him so let's jump
in here
Bobby plays one night f3 we have d5 and
then probably goes for g3 rather than
making an immediate claim in the center
you know no c4 Reddy's no d4
transpositions he's playing Knight f3
jeath
yeah Knight of 3 g3 going for these
types of system setups the Kings Indian
attack system where you just kind of
develop your pieces on the Kings side
you allow black to choose what setup he
wants to choose and then you're going to
you know decide how to play against it
in this game lineage shows to play the
move c5 which is actually one of the
more ambitious tries I believe against
the setup it is possible for black to
just play normal moves like Knight f6
even c6 and this is a slightly more
conservative way to play just making
your strong point on d5 here you know
you just kind of build a big triangle
with your pawns support this pawn on d5
and then from there you just develop
your pieces with c5 obviously this move
gives up a little bit of control over
the d5 square but in return you get
control over the d4 square and we'll see
that becomes really relevant later on so
Fabi just plays Bishop g2 we have E 6
from Leni a this pawn does need some
support Bobby castles we have Knight f6
see four and now we see Fabia trying to
break down these light squares and with
this move see five money I kind of
telegraphed what he's gonna do here he
pushes D for taking as much central
space as possible and that's why I think
this C five line is one of the more
combative lines for black now after the
move III we have knight c6 e takes d4 C
takes d4 and d3 and many of you might be
used to seeing this kind of position
from the other side with colors reversed
this of course is a reversed Benoni
style of position here you have black in
this case being the one with the strong
central pawns and you have white with
this V encoded bishop with this d3 c4
structure with this half open a file and
looking for play on the queenside
perhaps so what is the point in playing
a reversed opening like this well
obviously when you have the white pieces
you have the benefit of having an extra
tempo right and so it's all about is
that extra tempo going to be useful and
in the case of the benoni I really do
think it is a very useful tempo so it
makes sense to play the reversed wynonie
with this extra tempo white can actually
prevent a lot of the problems that kind
of plague the Benoni for example moves
like Bishop f5 are never going to be
possible whereas Bishop f4 lines against
the benoni are very very testing also
White has plenty of time as we see after
Bishop d6 to immediately just play this
move Bishop g5 and he's getting a lot of
these minor piece trades that black
generally has to work very very hard to
achieve in the benoni and when you play
it with white it just it does come a
little bit more naturally a little bit
more easily because you do have this
extra tempo and black is kind of on the
back foot trying to defend this Center
from the get-go okay Bishop g5 we have
h6 now Bishop takes f6 Queen takes f6 of
course white is usually happy to trade
off this Bishop in this opening in
Benoni structures you generally have
just one too many pieces for the number
of squares you have for example if this
bishop comes to d2 that's a good square
for the bish
supporting the pawn push before but then
all of a sudden your knight can't go to
d2 and so I trading off one piece it
allows the white pieces a little bit
more freedom to get where they need to
go so now we do see this Knight come out
to d2 and in this case it's not leaving
behind a bishop on c1 because we already
got rid of it Queen e7 now from black is
stepping out of this Knight e4 move and
now a3 by White's obviously in the
Benoni black generally plays for a6 b5
and the reverse Bodoni white is playing
for a 3 B 4 as well a very common plan
is it is in blacks best interest not to
allow this to come through for example
if you just play some nothing move like
castles
well now b4 is already going to because
you knew quite quite a lot of trouble
before c5 and all of a sudden you'll see
this would be a version of what white
got in the game but it would be a much
much much better version and we'll see
why in just a few moments so after a
three black plays a5 and this is the
standard way of stopping d4 now Ricky
one comes on the board from white black
goes ahead and gets castled and now
white play is a really interesting move
here it's the move rook c1 and the idea
is what you see on your board right
there he wants to push this pawn up to
see five black successfully for the
moment stopped white from playing before
he kind of placed all of his pieces with
this purpose to stop before and so what
Bobby's doing is saying that's fine I
don't need b4 to play C 5 C 5 is really
the important move instead of beef for
and once I play c5 I'm going to have a
ton of extra squares for my pieces and
this is the main plan in this position
for the white pieces here this has been
tried quite a number of times actually
and pretty much all the time they go for
this plan with c5 in high level games so
we see Bishop d7 this net comes up to e4
Bishop back to c7 and now we do see this
move
c5 come on the board and this looks like
a very loose looking move right you kind
of shove this pawn out there
and all of a sudden neither of these
pawns can really support this c5 pun
anymore
so you might think that this pawn is
going to be a really really big weakness
and you're not wrong but what white is
saying is almost that you would rather
not have this pond than have this pawn
at all and the reason for that is
because once the c4 pawn disappears once
this pawn is off the board all of whites
pieces start to make a lot more sense
and we'll see how Fabi
proved that in the skin he starts with
c5 and now black plays a slightly
strange-looking move rook a6
this move is aimed at guarding the d6
square a little bit guarding the b6
square a little bit and just kind of
clearing the way for an eventual b6 at a
later date this is what lenio wants to
do now we see Knight FD to buy a white
of course aiming for the c-4 square this
is the square vacated by the pawn and so
this is the first piece to benefit from
the removal of this pawn this Knight
coming to c4 Knight FD 2 though is
actually going to be a pawn sacrifice on
Ed of d2 is willingly sacrificing the c5
pawn after the move f5 the reason is
when you put this note on d2 you took
away this Knights only recruiting square
and that leaves this Knight with exactly
one Square to go to it has to jump to d6
and from there Lenny a does in fact
snatch this pawn so now the C pawn is
off the board Lenny a is happy because
he has an extra pawn Bobby is happy
because this gives his pieces the
opportunity to get really really really
active now all of a sudden this rook is
on a well placed square guarding are
attacking a backwards pawn on a
half-open file this Bishop is on the
best diagonal it can be on attacking
this b7 pawn and for the moment sitting
there on a post this night is coming
into the best square possible on c4
where can i squares like e5 squares like
b6 this queen is coming out to be three
on this exact move all of a sudden
attacking this e six pawn and will see
this rook it is well placed on c1 but
it's gonna get even more well placed now
that the C pawn is gone
coming to c5 actually immediately
after the move Queen be a queen bee
through of course attack this pawn and
now Queen p8 rook c5 so every single one
of Fabiana carolina's pieces is kind of
functioning at maximum capacity here
this is as active as his pieces can get
so after rook c5 black went ahead and
played King at age seven stepping out of
this pin stepping out of these threats
as well and now Fabi just brings this
night in to c4 and like I said all of
his piece pieces functioning at maximum
capacity Queen a7 hits this rook on c5
so the rook steps over to b5 hitting
this b7 pawn and now while fabi's pieces
are well placed at the end of the day
Lenny a Dominguez is going to be up upon
and so he had a little bit of a chance
here to try and claim he was ever so
slightly better but he did have to play
very very accurately in this moment so
of course with Rick b5 Fabi is
challenging this pawn on b7 and there
was really only one good way to start
evicting this rook from its placement
here on on b5 and that one way is to
play the move a for this gains extra
space on this Queen side takes away the
vital b3 squared from the Queen and if
this Queen were to retreat well now
there's a lot of different options for
black one of which is just this move
Knight a5 revealing a threat on the rook
if this Rick moves back now you might
get met with b5 and suddenly all of
those nice squares that you put your
pieces on are starting to be taken away
by by black here
this Knight can jump into e5 for example
but black is still doing quite alright
in this position with his extra pawn is
it enough for an edge maybe maybe not
but definitely black is very much in the
game here instead of a 4 Lenny I came up
with this move Knight d8 and this looks
like it does the same you know it
defends the b7 pawn and attacks this
rook and probably Lenny a expected Fabi
just play a move like rook to e5 just
kind of admitting ok you attacked my
rook I'll move out of the way instead
though father came up with a really
really nice move
here so I'll let you guys at home take a
second to try to find it I'm go ahead
pause the video if you would like but
I'm gonna reveal it now the move of
course is the move a four this is really
uh you know an incredible move by Fabi
here the point is if you do capture this
rook a takes b5 and all of a sudden this
work is left with absolutely no squares
to jump to so Bishop c6 instead Queen
over to a three hits a rook on f8 so
King f8 gets played and now Fabi has
kind of his choice of really great moves
he can jump this Queen into e7 it
chooses ninety five instead now take
some Chi to King takes G to be six tries
to keep the Queen out of a seven but
that's okay we have another square
available and that is the square on d6
Queen d6
now Queen b7 check and Fabi just plays
King back to g1 in hindsight the move f3
might have been a little bit more
practical in this case rather than you
know allowing all these holes in your
position f3 you know makes a new
weakness on e3 but it is pretty relevant
to have some light square defense here
kingi one instead Ricky 8 and now Fabi
kind of makes the move that despite his
pretty nice place so far it kind of
throws away the advantage if Lenny
Dominguez plays accurately of course
best here was actually the simple move
you just take a free pawn on d4 instead
Fabi plays the Knight to c4 and now
Lenny a does find the best move Knight
f7 Queen takes d4 and suddenly after
Knight g5 you start to realize that you
do have some weaknesses around your King
and they're not so easy to defend this F
3 square is is pretty brutal and just
for comparison if Bobby had played f3
here and let's say Ricky eights just the
same as we just saw Knight to g5 1 now
he would have a ton more options
including the move played in the game
just Knight back to e5 you know this
king staying on g2 does defend these
light squares a little bit better ok
though so we have 95 and now in this
case 95 is the only move for Fabi Neddy
three check still comes on the board
King f1 and now Lenny eight did miss his
chance to kind of have a lot of
compensation here you could have played
the move Queen H one check and then
either Queen takes age to word just
Queen back to g2 keeping an eye on the
light squares and with pressure on the
f2 pawn pressure around this King
this is definite compensation for for
black here you know I'm saying
compensation like lenny a's down massive
amounts material he's not yet but these
Queen side ponds are in fact just going
to die in the near future given enough
time so that's why it kind of feels like
black is kind of playing desk with
desperation here trying to get at this
white King before everything collapses
and so the engine says this is about
equal practically I might even prefer to
be black here just because this white
king is looking so so dangerous out here
in the open instead though Lenny I
placed the move rook a to a eighths and
now Fabi plays the best move you at home
might want to try to find this one for
yourself it shows great practical
understanding by Fabiano karamaneh it's
a move that really solidifies your King
and just almost immediately crushes all
hopes of an attack against this guy of
course that move is the move f3 the the
move I've been talking about for a while
now f3 cuts off this Queen from invading
on the Kings side and now the King can
come back to g2 and it's just a much
more solid setup for for white black
tried Rick a to d8 but this was a little
bit too friendly now giving up this beep
on immediately and this is just busted
now for Lenny a queen a8 plate in the
game rook takes a5 Queen over to c8 of
course at this point letting it down to
just like 10 seconds so all of this just
kind of time pressure work back to c5
Queen a8 Queen c6 b8 desperately trying
to avoid the Queen trade and eventually
96 by Fabi rook up to d6 King up to g2 9
g5 h for bullies this night a little bit
night f7 d4 and it's now at the end of
the day Fabi is just up to passed pawns
on this Queen side his king is safe this
night has been ejected and you know all
of his pieces are better
than all of blacks pieces what more can
you ask for King age seven a five
Rickover's see it rookie to see one perk
up to see 7v4 and now g5 just kind of a
last-ditch effort trying to get this
Knight back into the game but Bobby just
pushes these pawns even further
Rick g7 bring back to e2 just a little
bit of Defense Queen over to g8 I mean
up to e5 Knight of seven queen of four
and now Queen a8 giving up on the attack
and once black gives up on the attack he
kind of gives up on the game b5 is
played
Rick d7 d5 Hobby pushes every one of his
pawns Knight g5 d takes c6 Knight takes
c6 between a5 check 3695 and the end is
is near d2 check King f1 and in this
position Lenny and Dominguez went ahead
and resigned so that is it for me today
on a game review
hopefully enjoyed this game from Fabiano
Keira wanna really highlighting this
nice idea in the reverse benoni of
playing c5 giving your pieces some
activity and then how to play with that
activity to convert into a win hopefully
you enjoy it that's it for me today and
I will see you next time on game review